il
simplicité
krieger
je suis sur bernadette
si vous m'avez je suis religieuses
depuis une trentaine d'années ici nous
sommes à la communauté du bon pasteur au
100 rue saint-joseph ouvriers je vais
vous dire oui nous sommes à 4 en ce
moment auparavant nous étions quatorze
religieuse vous voulez savoir exactement
mais se dit bon ici c'est la chapelle
nous sommes religieuse donc nous
commençons notre jeu commence ma zone et
par la prière
chaque semaine nous prions pour un pays
parce que nous sommes implantés dans 72
pays
depuis tout jeune je fréquentais les des
communautés religieuses gta souvent à
l'église est comme ça j'ai eu ce désir
un choix de consacrer ma vie pour
travailler pour le bien des personnes
soit bernadette est simple je pense de
par son caractère qui est assez facile
ce ne sont pas des soeurs contemplatives
quoi elle pris mais elles agissent leur
mission c'est principalement à aider les
femmes en détresse
c'était la mission de leur fondateur et
elle essaie de continuer dans ce domaine
j'ai été embauché comme auxiliaire
puériculture mais au début c'était plus
pour travailler auprès des enfants et
des meilleurs mais au fur et à mesure
dans dans mon travail je me suis rendu
compte que ce n'était pas suffisant
ah je vais 50 ans que ce comment si je
les ai eus à 52 ans il y avait une autre
collègue avec moi qui me dit alors en ce
moment on peut prendre les livres
qu'elle avait été à eux et je me suis
lancé comme ça à des pouilles
j'ai commencé après que j'étais dedans
ce duo j'étais vraiment folle de faire
ça parce que c'est quand même il faut
fall et devenez du temps parce qu'il
fallait travailler et à côté faire des
études et écrire étudié à les alliés ts
beaucoup de tensions mais heureusement
le seigneur m'a donné la force la
capacité pour tenir les pour aller
jusqu'au bout
nous sommes sur la structure des
amaretti de cette structure fait partie
de l'association a marre et on nous
accueillons les merdes adolescents les
mamans sont scolarisés elles sont à
l'école donc nous prenons en charge les
enfants jusqu'à leur toit et après je
vais faire des activités avec les
meilleurs on va faire la gestion du
budget et celle du crochet pour pas
content mais c'est tellement émotif
ça fait partie de notre charisme de la
congrégation
donc c'est comme ça que j'ai j'ai
commencé même depuis l'afrique
si c'est la nurserie ou mais vous faites
tout les les bains libres où il y a huit
mamans entre 13 et 18 ans
à taunoa tonneau alina marzouk commence
exactement ne ce n'est pas toujours
évident d'être adolescents et d'être
ouverts en même temps elles ont un peu
et ré où elle faisait ce qu'elle voulait
auparavant elle n'avait pas de cadre des
limites donc ont déjà on commence à
poser aussi le cadre et les limites
elles savent qu'elles peuvent sortir à
telle heure à telle heure elles doivent
être rentrées on n'est pas là pour juger
parce que on ne sait pas ce qu'est ce
qu'il ya eu
parce que ces personnes ils ont
peut-être porter des choses difficiles
elles elles ont crû en labourd peut-être
en disant ben si j'ai un enfant mais je
serai mai et puis finalement c'est parce
c'est pas sûr et blake qui serait à
ville qu'on fait que suivre puisque
effectivement c'est c'est un modèle un
exemple à aide à la fois des résidentes
qui sont ici et nous - personnellement
j'ai une professionnelle quoi pour elle
c'est aussi une vocation d'aider les
autres donc du coup le côté religieux je
pense que ça
voilà ça ça donne encore plus du poisson
travaille je travaille avec ce que je
suis avec mes valeurs et leur travail
avec ce qu'elle est avec ses valeurs et
enfin bébé après on se respecte donc
dans ce conte est cher qu'une approche
sa richesse
et ça les aide à prendre ça fait un
bouquet
mais si tu es pauvre l'avenir en reste
j'espère que dieu lui prête longue vie
et qu'elle puisse avoir la santé pour
nous montrer le chemin aussi de
dévouement aux autres supports science
ben oui parce que je prends la personne
je crois qu'elle est capable de se
relever de leur parti
et des personnes
qui peuvent la retraite de véniard